Musik
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, Sekunde vorbei.
Geht das hier? Ja, Pfunst.
Jo.
du hast die letzten Monate
ich hab einmal gestreamt die letzten Monate
ich kann gerade nicht wirklich viel streamen
sondern
aber es ist besser
es wird in nächster Zeit wieder mehr
also überlegt euch das mit subscriben
wartet erstmal
bis ich das dann auch wirklich mache
was ich jetzt sag
ich hab eine Sache erledigt
die hat mir sehr viel Kopfzerbrechen
bereitet.
Also das schon vor 2-3 Wochen.
Das war es nicht.
Ich werde nie ganz aufhören mit Streamen und YouTube.
Ja, und die Sache ist halt die,
nachdem gestern
eben Season 3 gestartet ist
und ich eh den 24-7-Kreisel-Crime
mache,
machen wir das heute einfach im Stream.
Also wer nicht weiß, was wir spielen,
Max spielt uralte
20 Jahre alte Boomer Games.
Dark Age of Camelot auf einem Freeshot.
Das Game sieht aus wie aus dem Jahr 2000.
Und es ist auch aus dem Jahr 2001.
Nix, Avklo.
Avklo war schon.
Ja, und...
Ich sitze heute eh die nächsten 10 Stunden hier.
Und mache Kreiselgrind.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir können auch ein bisschen schwätzen.
Und wir machen zusammen Kreiselgrind.
Dass es nicht so farblos aussieht,
mache ich mal kurz hier gerade mal andere Settings
an, dann sieht es ein bisschen besser aus.
Muss mich gerade mal schauen, ob das, ja,
das ist besser. Der Chat ist
auch okay, den Chat kann man auch nicht lesen.
Ansonsten ist alles gut.
Ja, Chat, geht.
Es geht bei euch so.
Schön, dass wir wieder alle
am Start sind.
Wir müssen heute jede Menge Sachen machen
im Game.
Ich muss
meinen Heiler 50 machen.
Muss die Epic erledigen für den Heiler.
dann die anderen Chars leveln
BGs machen
eventuell Raids mitmachen, je nachdem was so
was so kommt
und
ich muss meinen Heiler vor allem mal ordentlich specken
warum ich so lange weg war
das kann ich jetzt noch nicht
erzählen
das erzähle ich euch vielleicht mal irgendwann
Das erzähle ich euch vielleicht mal irgendwann.
Da sage ich jetzt nichts zu.
Ja.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich da bin.
Auch in nächster, auch in näherer Zukunft noch nicht.
Müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, heute ist eh 10 Stunden Dark-Kreisel-Crime angesagt.
Und ich habe das ja schon ein paar Mal gestreamt.
Immer wieder, wenn eine neue Season anfängt,
bin ich da für, keine Ahnung, 4-5 Monate am Daily-Crime.
Mehrere Stunden.
Aber hat sich deine Sache jetzt zumindest vollständig geklärt?
Ja, ja, die eine Sache hat sich vollständig geklärt.
gibt da noch so ein paar andere Sachen drumherum
die sind aber
gar nicht mal so schlimm
ja
tja, jetzt mal so
als Intro
für alle, die das Game nicht kennen, wovon ich mal
ausgehe, weil das ist uralt, ich hab das zwar
schon ein paar mal gestreamt und ich weiß, dass das
auch nicht für jeden ist, also
feel free
zu gucken, wir können über alles schwätzen
wenn es nichts für euch ist, dann
kann ich daran auch nichts ändern
Das sind uralte, wahrscheinlich zum Zugucken relativ langweilige MMOs.
Außer für die Leute, die es gespielt haben.
Da ist das wahrscheinlich, denke ich, ganz nice.
Aber ich gucke mal, dass wir es halbwegs abwechslungsreich machen.
Weil ich muss relativ viel erledigen.
Wir spielen Dark Edge of Camelot.
Das ist ein uraltes MMO von 2001.
Hauptsächlich mit dem Fokus auf PvP.
Ich sehe übrigens wie der letzte Kack-Noob aus, weil ich der letzte Kack-Noob bin.
Ich bin Level 48.
Ich habe gestern erst wieder angefangen zu Season Start.
Und ich bin jetzt 48.
Das heißt, ja, ich würde gerne die Epic machen.
Und ich muss den Heiler vor allem ordentlich specken.
Ansonsten kann ich mal ganz kurz...
Ich kann aber ganz kurz...
Stimmt, ich muss noch gucken, wie ich eigentlich specke.
Ich kann euch mal ganz kurz erklären, um was das Game geht
Für die, die
Vielleicht vor einem Jahr bei dem Stream nicht dabei waren
Oder so, was die meisten waren
Also, im Prinzip ist das ein MMO
Wie man MMOs kennt, bloß mit dem Fokus auf PvP
Es gibt ein Grenzgebiet
Das ist das hier, es gibt drei Reiche
Midgard
Hibernia, Albion
Albion ist quasi England
Midgard ist quasi Wikinger
Und Hibernia ist so keltisch
Angehaucht, ja
und jedes Reich hat ein Grenzgebiet mit Festungen, Türmen, Relikten und das kann man einnehmen.
So, im Prinzip ist das hier eigentlich ein ziemlich, wie nennt man das so schön,
neudeutsch Sandbox MMO.
Also es gibt zwar ein paar fertige PvM-Encounter und Contents und so,
aber gerade auf Eden, also Eden ist ein, vielleicht kann ich das hier gerade nochmal zeigen,
da auch Eden, Eden ist ein
Free-Shard, die haben sehr viel
geändert, zum besseren
ja, also man levelt
viel angenehmer und die haben
saumäßig viel Zeug eingeführt
wo ich selbst noch gar keinen Durchblick
habe, weil ich hab aufgehört
so sagen wir mal so 60, 70
Prozent zu Season 2
und dann hab ich gar nicht mehr
geguckt und die haben saumäßig viel neue Sachen
eingeführt, die haben irgendwelche
Missionen für alle Gruppengrößen
eingeführt und total viel Zeug
Ich bin da selbst nicht auf dem Laufenden.
Und
heute machen wir aber nicht so viel
in der Richtung, also nicht Richtung
großes PvP. Heute leveln
wir mal unsere Chars.
Und machen vielleicht
ein bisschen im BG.
Also was ich heute machen muss, ist,
ich muss das hier mal ausstellen, weil es crasht sonst, wenn ich auslogge.
Also, heute
übrigens, beste
Grafik, ne?
beste Graphics.
Es gibt
für alle, die sagen,
Alter, wie kann man sich das angucken?
Naja, es gibt tatsächlich noch eine Option.
Da kann man irgendwo,
frag mich nicht, wo das ist.
Das benutze ich
eh nicht.
Es gibt neue,
neuere Settings,
neue Graphics Settings.
Da sehen die Charaktermodelle
deutlich besser. Bin ich blöd? Wo ist das denn?
Jetzt muss ich...
Classic eigen...
Configure Figure Versions.
Ich sehe es nicht. Wo ist es denn? Bin ich jetzt total blind?
Classic.
Unter... Alter!
Wie kommt man da drauf, dass man die Models unter Wasseroptionen hat?
Na egal. Ja, also man kann hier einstellen...
einstellen dass man auch die neuen models verwenden will aber ich mag die neuen models nicht ich
Ich zeige euch mal die neuen models ok kette kommt dann weiß ich auch dafür neu starten muss
guckt dann sehen die dann sehen ein bisschen
dann sehen ein bisschen besser aus aber auch nicht auch nicht wirklich so geil aber zumindest zumindest sehen die nicht aus wie
2001 aber ich mag das nicht ich mag die ja und insgesamt sieht dann in game auch ein bisschen besser aus
Aber ich mag
Wenn schon, wenn schon muss das richtig
Alt und reudig aussehen
Nur dann ist das original
Ja
Also ich muss heute mal ein Heiner 50 machen
Ich muss die Epic machen, ich muss ein bisschen Currency farmen
Dann werde ich
Mein Skalde, mein Shami
Und eventuell den Runilevel
Da muss ich mal schauen
Ob es irgendwelche Levelgruppen gibt
Und nebenbei
Habe ich noch den
Discord offen auf dem zweiten Bildschirm
und gucke, ob's... Mist, jetzt habe ich mich gerade
ausgeloggt. Ich kack noob. Jetzt kann ich mich nochmal...
Eingeloggt. Jetzt kann ich mich gleich nochmal ausloggen.
Weil
ich spiele nicht nur...
Ich spiele
nicht nur auf Mid. Ich habe auch Chars
in Albion
und da
level ich eine Zorg oder eine Cleric und
in Hip habe ich tatsächlich noch irgendwo
einen Bade.
Pog Tasty.
Da habe ich aber auf
hip habe ich heute keinen bock richtiger kreisel klein heute ist kreisel kreisel
kein zehn stunden am stück kreisel kreisel ist heute angesagt mindestens
ich habe gestern gespielt von 13 uhr bis 24 uhr durch das habe ich lange nicht
mehr gemacht so aber wir spielen erst mal auf mit weiter ich habe den discord
offen ich glaube mal wieder auf mein heil ein ich habe den discord offen sollte
eine Hip- oder eine
Alp-Level-Gruppe starten,
bisschen was organisiertes über Discord,
hab ich da einen Blick drauf,
dann join ich vielleicht da rein.
Ansonsten gucken wir mal.
Natürlich ist jetzt
ein kleines Problem. Ich hab mit Heiler
angefangen und Heiler ist eine Klasse.
Ich porte mal kurz hier weg.
Hier ist mir zu voll. Ich porte mal
hier nach SI irgendwo.
Oder ins Tutorial. Ich porte ins Tutorial.
mal gucken wie viele tutorial los ist tutorial gebiet ja weil man muss dazu sagen ich versuche
man könnte mich übrigens zu dem ich könnte mich alles fragen ihr könnt mich auch zu dem game
alles fragen schießt schießt einfach los das wird heute ein recht entspannter wie nennt man
so low intensity stream übrigens diese sache mit den mit den grafik settings das ist nicht ingame
Das ist ein...
Kann man das Plugin nennen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist ein Plugin, das nennt sich Reshade.
Ich kann übrigens auch meinen Helm aufsetzen.
Das sieht aber richtig dumm aus.
Und ich könnte...
Und ich könnte tatsächlich auch
meinen Umhang anziehen.
Aber ich sehe halt richtig
Noob-Low-Level aus.
Ist das ihr UI?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es das.
Der Text, warum der Text verpixelt ist, kann ich dir sagen, weil das Hauptmenü wahrscheinlich
nur in 1024x768 hat Hardcoded Rendered und dann 800x600 keine Ahnung.
Aber das mit Cloak sieht, ohne Cloak sieht es einfach besser aus.
Dann sieht man hier auch mal einen Proggers Hammer.
also da ist das spiel das ist sowas von old school das ist vor world of warcraft rausgekommen und ist
quasi noch wirklich so in richtung als ihr habt ihr mal quest gespielt also es geht es geht
eindeutig eher in die in die pre world of warcraft schiene also es ist mehr oder weniger jedem frei
gestellt was er macht es gibt so mäßig viele klassen und es gibt für jeden etwas also ich
habe noch kein ohne scheiß ich habe noch kein mmo gespielt kann ich das mal kurz zeigen ich habe
noch kein mmo gespielt und ich habe gerade in dieser zeit so gut wie alles gespielt haben fabian
zusammen.
Okay.
Da haben sie natürlich die hässlichsten Bilder aller Zeiten
genommen.
Gab es nicht mal ein Dark Wiki oder sowas?
Glass. Ja. Perfekt.
Glasses.
Genau.
Ich habe noch kein MMO gesehen
wie Dark und ich habe vor allem
kein MMO gesehen, was so eine
schöne, abwechslungsreiche
Klassenvielfalt hat, wo für jeden was dabei ist.
Also das ist übrigens
der Free-Shot, auf dem ich spiele. Kostet nix.
Hat auch eine Anleitung, how to play.
Letztendlich müsst ihr euch nur mit dem Discord-Account
einloggen und dann passt was.
Also das ist wirklich gut gemacht.
Also wer Bock hat, das mal auszuprobieren.
Ich muss aber sagen,
es ist für mich
das beste Game,
zumindest das beste MMO aller Zeiten.
Es sieht halt
ein bisschen aus wie 2001. Es ist halt auch
2001, aber
ich habe noch kein besseres MMO gespielt
und werde wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder ein besseres MMO finden.
Falls jemand Bock hat, das auszuprobieren,
ich kann euch nur ermutigen,
das auf Eden mal auszuprobieren. Eden kostet nichts.
Kann man einfach einsteigen, Discord
Clip Play loslegen.
Gibt es auch eine Anleitung auf der Seite.
Aber ihr müsst ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen.
Ihr könnt mich ja alles fragen im Stream.
Ich werde noch ein bisschen was zeigen.
Aber ihr müsst ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen, weil
Dark ist halt
gerade in den Default Settings,
wo ich schon viel umgestellt habe, ist mega oldschool.
Also zum Beispiel
ist es halt noch
ja, es ist noch, es ist
Tap-Targeting. Also du musst Tap
oder anklicken.
Wenn ich den Dude hier jetzt
heilen will,
dann muss ich den anklicken
und muss ein Heal-Spell drücken.
Oder wie es die Noobs machen, die klicken dann
hier oben auf der Spell-Leiste rum oder so.
Hi.
Kenn ich den?
Guck, die Leute interagieren in diesem Spiel noch.
The fuck?
Ach, das ist Jura.
Okay.
Jetzt sehe ich Invite.
Gilden Invite.
Ich vergesse ja immer, dass ich Leute in die Gilde einladen kann.
Wie geht's dir?
Mir geht's besser.
Mir geht's besser als die letzten paar Monate.
Um zumindest jetzt mal ein Gedanke zu Ende zu führen.
Ich habe mal hier nebenbei immer noch einen Blick auf den Chat.
Den Chat könnt ihr nicht sehen, aber ich schaue gerade, ob es...
Ah, okay, da können wir mitmachen.
Da machen wir mit.
Wir machen jetzt einen Braindead PVE-Rate mit.
Muss mal kurz gucken.
Wie war
WC
Healer
LFG
Wir machen jetzt mal ein Brain
Instant, als Heiler hast du Instant Invite
Instant Invite
Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal kurz in den Dungeon
Dann kann ich weiter schwätzen
Äh, wo war das nochmal?
Trollheim.
Pjaken?
Ich glaube, Pjaken war das.
Ich porte mal da kurz hin.
Es war entweder Haggard oder Pjaken.
Ich glaube, Pjaken.
Ich habe jetzt ein Dreivierteljahr nicht gespielt.
Also kein Plan.
Pjaken.
Okay, nice.
Gab es hier nicht irgendwie Speed?
Ah, ich habe noch 5 Minuten Speed.
Okay, let's go.
Ja, ich bin richtig.
Hier auf der Map oben sieht man es.
Da muss ich hin hier. Dungeon.
Ich hab, Alter, ich hab noch nicht mal
nen Endo-Trank. Ich hab nix.
So, und als Heiler sollte man tunlichst,
by the way, sollte man tunlichst
nicht out of Endo gehen.
Ich renn da jetzt hin.
Nicht, nicht out of Endo gehen,
weil, wenn du Gegner nicht wegrennen kannst,
als Heiler hast du gelitten.
Komm, ich mach mal, dass es nicht ganz so doof aussieht.
meinen Umhang an.
Und du kannst als Heiler nix killen.
Um jetzt mal den Gedanken von eben fortzuführen,
ja. Also Dark ist das
MMO, was ich kenne mit der besten Klassenvielfalt
ever. Also ich kenne kein besseres,
äh, besser designtes MMO in dieser
Richtung. Es ist für jeden irgendwas dabei.
Es ist sowohl, ähm,
quasi in dem Realm, wo er spielt,
als auch von den Klassen her ist es für jeden was dabei.
Und
es ist aber ein Oldschool MMO,
das heißt, es gibt Klassen,
die können alleine nix.
Und das sind so gut wie
fast alle Supportklassen, wobei es da ein paar
Ausnahmen gibt.
Wenn wir hier im
Dungeon drin sind, dann kann ich euch auch mal
ein paar Skilltrees und so zeigen.
Aber die meisten Supportklassen in Dauer
kriegen alleine nix auf die Reihe, kriegen alleine nix
gekillt. Also wenn ich
Mobs an mir dran hab
als Heiler, ich kann nix machen.
Ich kann die ein bisschen betäuben und wegrennen.
Das ist das Einzige, was ich machen kann. Ich kann die nicht killen.
Übrigens, ich hab noch nicht mal fertig geskillt.
Geschweige denn meine eigentliche Skillung.
Ich lass das jetzt einfach mal alles so wie es ist.
Ich hab keine Cubines, ich hab alles auf die Leiste geklatscht und fertig.
They are moving.
Leute, wir sind auf die Sekunde pünktlich.
Oh fuck, ich muss die Quest annehmen.
Okay, wait.
Accept, nice.
Okay, let's go.
Wir sind auf die Sekunde.
sind wir rechtzeitig gekommen wie los so da auch pv ist easy as fuck man geht in
die menge rein und zerr surft sich durch den ganzen durch übrigens jeder name
hier oben ist ein echter spieler und die klasse hier ist neu dieses season die
bombe hier die klasse mit diesen bomben das ist ein warlock den gibt es jetzt
erst mit diesen drei war war im base game sehr verhasste klasse weil opf als
rausgekommen ist ich muss mal kurz die leute baffen
ich habe ich habe auch einen buff marco irgendwo gemacht
Caster.
So.
Okay, nice.
Gut.
Ich hab's rechtzeitig geschafft.
Jetzt kann ich im Prinzip einfach sticken und nix machen.
In Trollheim muss man ein bisschen gucken.
Das ist so ein ziemlich...
Ein bisschen Multilayer-Dungeon.
Da kann man runterfallen.
Also wenn man gar zu...
Gar zu braindead unterwegs ist...
Dann...
Hält man runter und stirbt.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Moin.
Der konnte doch so Zauber in eine Kammer packen und instant raushauen, wenn er Bock hat.
Ja, genau.
Warlock ist eigentlich eines der speziellsten Klassen im Game.
Diese Mechanic hat sonst keine andere Klasse.
Man kann quasi Zauber, anstatt sie zu casten, kann man sie quasi zwischenspeichern.
Und dann instant auslösen.
Deswegen waren die auch super OP.
Die können auch ein bisschen mehr, ja, aber
im Prinzip kannst du verschiedene
Zauberkombinationen, kannst du verschiedene Zauber
kombinieren
und du zauberst die dann quasi im Voraus
und speicherst die in so einer Blase hier
und dann kannst du die quasi instant auslösen, wenn du sie brauchst.
Aber halt nur maximal vier Stück.
Ansonsten hast du ziemlich lahme Cast-Zeit.
Wobei, du hast noch mehr. Also Warlock ist
keine Einsteiger-Klasse, würde ich sagen. Ein bisschen
Game-Knowledge ist da nicht verkehrt.
Oh, ich muss buffen. Ja, ja, mach ich.
Ich werde wieder aktiver in nächster Zeit.
Ja, ja, ja. Werde ich.
Werde ich. Aber wie gesagt,
wartet mal mit dem Subscriben und alles.
Ich muss erst mal gucken,
wie das wird. Ich habe ein paar Probleme aus der Welt
geschafft, aber es ist noch nicht alles gelöst.
Ähm, ja. Wie gesagt, ich habe auch noch,
ich habe weder mein, ich habe noch nicht mal alles geskillt.
Ich habe noch
531 Skillpunkte übrig.
Ich specke aber eh um.
Ich gehe dann wieder auf Tree-Spec.
und Treespec Heiler
ist meiner bescheidenen
Meinung nach die
komplexeste Klasse im Spiel.
Zumindest wurde die meisten Knöpfe und
Sachen verbraucht, aber macht mega
Spaß.
Quest habe ich angenommen.
Ich könnte noch ein bisschen Attack Speed
geben.
Ja.
Oh, Buffs habe ich noch 44% frei.
Also wenn ihr, wenn ihr Darug anfangen wollt,
es ist ein super, super rewarding Game auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt kaum ein MMO, was ich gespielt habe,
was so lang Zeit motiviert wie Darug.
Ihr müsst aber ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen,
weil das ist halt alt und hat so ein paar Mechanics.
Darug erklärt halt nichts.
Darug ist ein Spiel, das schmeißt dich rein
und sagt, okay, ich will jetzt mal ein paar Sachen machen.
mach mal.
Es gibt kein, doch, es gibt ein Tutorial-Gebiet
bis Level 10, aber da lernt man auch
nicht so wirklich viel.
Also,
das, das, Dork schmeißt, wir fangen nachher auch
die anderen Chars noch anzuleveln,
dann werdet ihr es sehen.
Dork schmeißt euch in das Game
rein.
Können wir jetzt moven, please?
Ach, das Plo ist wieder am Start, den hatte ich gestern auch
in meinem Level-Group.
Also, Dork schmeißt euch, schmeißt euch
ins Game und
oh fuck, was machen die hier denn?
Der Mage.
Da schmeißt er euch ins Game und sagt, ja,
mach mal, easy.
By the way, Leute, wie ist eigentlich die
Stream-Quali? Soll ich die noch ein bisschen hochstellen?
Muss mir das
gerade mal kurz in der Vorschau angucken.
Das ist ein bisschen pixelig, oder?
Ein bisschen
pixelig? Wartet mal, ich gucke
mal kurz.
Wo haben wir denn hier OBS?
Bei dem Game egal.
Output.
Ich habe nur 4900.
Sollen wir mal 5900 machen?
Machen wir mal 5900.
Ist das jetzt besser?
Kann das überhaupt
on the fly hochstellen?
Ich hab nie ausprobiert.
Moment, ich muss mir das mal kurz im Vorschau-Rechner angucken, wie das ausschaut.
Und mal gucken, dass meine Leute nicht sterben.
Die sind nämlich gerade am verrecken.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wo er ist.
Wo ist er denn?
Alter, wo ist denn der Dude?
Ach da.
Okay.
Ne, hä?
Okay, heil, heil, Sohn.
So, ich muss jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen gerade, weil wir sind alle ziemlich low-level und ohne Equipment und sonst was.
und mein brain funktioniert nicht richtig also ich meine ich bin 40 das ist kein wunder
nochmal schauen ob das jetzt okay anstein anscheinend wie geht das hier vorschau da
konnte man noch irgendwie sagen ich hoffe mal ich kann dem typ hier folgen ohne dass
runterfalle man konnte doch irgendwie sagen advanced video stats
4000 das geht nicht das hat da nichts dran
geändert
also ich würde sagen es ist ein bisschen zu pixel ich oder wir können ruhig die
können ruhig mal die bestellen wir stellen aber ein bisschen hoch wobei
eigentlich ist es so in bewegung ist er sich weil hier ist halt ziemlich viel
ja ja das ist das pixel ein bisschen in bewegung ich stelle ich stelle noch mal
ein bisschen hoch klar müssen wir sagen ob ich so lassen kann oder oder nicht
hier fallen die leute immer gerne runter und sterben
Deswegen bleibe ich mal kurz oben stehen und heile mal proaktiv.
Guck, es gibt immer viele Leute, die sagen, oh, ups, ich bin fast tot.
Gerade weil unten auch ein Mob ist, der die Leute killt.
Ich habe übrigens keinen Plan, wo wir hin müssen.
Ich checke das nicht.
Wo müssen wir hin?
müssen wir überhaupt runter
hier lang
hier lang müssen wir okay
Keck Wade, Alter.
Ich hoffe, ich werde nicht angegriffen, sonst bin ich dead.
Als Heiler bist du instant, bist du...
Bist du...
Bist im Arsch.
Wenn du einen Mob am Arsch hast.
Ich habe übrigens keinen Speed
gelaufen, was ziemlich dumm ist.
Aber was willst du machen?
Ah, da vorne sind sie. Okay, nice.
Ja, stell hoch, mach ich.
Kann sein, dass ich den Stream für noch...
Lollala.
Hatten wir nicht eben noch einen zweiten Heiler?
Okay.
Ich spam mal eine Runde Heal.
Und dann PR'en wir den Dude mal.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der ist.
Wo ist er denn?
Da unten ist er.
Alter.
Mein Brain kann ich mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig processen.
Ich muss mal Speed machen,
dass ich, wenn ich schon alleine bin, hinterher komme.
So. Gut.
So, eigentlich wollte ich Brain.net PVE-Content machen.
So.
Okay.
Gucken, ob das, wenn ich das hier hochstelle,
auf Output...
Ach, es ist Constant Bitrate.
deswegen geht das vielleicht nicht.
6.900. Gucken wir mal.
Warum habe ich es auf
Constant Bitrate stehen?
Nee, das geht nicht hoch.
Ich glaube, ich muss
den...
Ich glaube, ich muss den Stream kurz neu starten. Lass das funzt.
Ich starte mal ganz kurz
neu. In der Sekunde ist der Stream wieder da. Ich mache
kurz aus und wieder an direkt.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.